for decades conspiracy theorists have
accused the government of engaging in a
massive cover-up to hide the truth about
aliens at area 51 now more than a
million people say they are ready to
storm the top-secret site to find out
what's really going on the viral
Facebook event claims that if enough
people show up the military will not be
able to stop them from getting inside
it's scheduled for September Jesse
Ashton the commercial break the exact
date so it's September the 20th Jesse
from 3 a.m. to 6 a.m. Pacific time the
Air Force is telling people to stay away
saying they will defend the base if
necessary you're a joiner well I'll tell
you why you don't want to know the date
I consider myself a kook anthropologist
I have studied druggies in the wild
nudists in their natural habitat
communists anarchists pretty much
everybody that makes you a legit
cultural and yes I really am and so
these people need to be seen which is
why water's world cameras will be there
on September 20th to capture all the
action all the coups will be coming out
of the woodwork
I am surprised Trump has not slipped up
about area 51 yet the man cannot keep a
secret I don't even think they probably
told him about area 51 because he'll
just like let it go at a rally or
something like that but if he has kept
the secret I'm very proud now I believe
these little green guys you could eat
them they taste delicious
it's sad they're so smart but I had you
Skype my web my point can I make a point
what are these people gonna do when they
show up wearing their lacrosse helmet
you know with their soccer shin guards
brandishing a metal broom when they come
up to a dude with a military ID
brandishing an ar-15 I don't think
you're gonna be crossing this line I
think that little is that your outfit is
not gonna work but Dana is it a joke or
not a joke there was some guy who put
that apparently put the original
Facebook post up like let's go do this
on September 20
and he says he was joking problem is you
know no one has a sense of humor anymore
that's true so everyone thought it was
serious and now he's actually saying no
like you guys I was kidding but it could
get a life of its own because people
don't have anything enough to do it's a
yes this is a great time to be alive
that you can actually take a few days
off and go storm you know some kind of
folk Lord but like we have a great
economy with peace this is our problem
yeah meantime the Kardashian sisters
like oh my god you know Coachella is
both chic and then Burning Man is kind
of Halloween so what do we wear to area
that they were but I want to just
quickly show this because this is
generated this posting on Facebook has
generated a lot of memes and this one
made me laugh out loud what are we
really going to find when we get to area
51
it's a Dollar General so that's I guess
some rural southern chamber because that
may be we got plenty of dollar generals
as well all over the state of Ohio but
look I kind of want to go I myself am
curious because I do want to see like
beat the clientele that shows up are
they real are they serious will you
actually have you know astrophysicist
well Bryan may show up cuz he's an
astrophysicist really I want to see
whether or not there are aliens here I
mean what are we gonna get but
apparently this is the other thing to be
sort of serious but it's actually kind
of ridiculous now they're actually
talking about if these four hundred
thousand people show up the government
is actually going to invest resources in
basically exactly what you're talking
about dudes with ar-15s to fight off the
crazy so how many tax dollars are
actually going to be spent to protect
little green men with pencil necks like
Adam Schiff but you know it's it there's
only three people are gonna show up
because none of these guys are gonna
afford a bus ticket to get there
just watch the Dro Joe Rogan interview
with Bob Lazar that's all you have to do
I think if you have a prediction I did a
waters real package at an alien UFO
abductees conference and we polled the
audience who they'd vote for Hillary or
Trump not at a 10 or Trump supporters
and you know why cuz he's gonna spill
all the secrets
that's why Declassified okay and we did
skip all the FISA applications let's see
area 51 documents we did find out in
2017
pentagons finally confirmed the
existence of that 22 million dollar
program to analyze basically look into
UFOs what a waste of money
22 million that's it or anything only
people here let's face it we would have
found out a long time ago you know that
either that or the aliens are super
stupid like they're like they're like
they're like our version of like
salamanders or whatever there's if he
can't they can stay all dry they can't
do anything we're the only people here
it's pretty cool it's our place yeah
that's right we're just living in it yes
we accept aliens in waters world I don't
those are the aliens we like just one
hand
just one yeah David what are you doing I
just you're butchering it really really
just screwed up